[Music]
foreign
Cuoco and Tom Pelfrey celebrate their
baby's first Easter I think it's going
to be interesting for people to see me
what you know this new phase in life and
just being very open about it on Sunday
the new mama shared a few snaps to her
insta story that's Tom holding their
newborn daughter Matilda while Kaylee
lays a kiss on her forehead it was all
the things and it is such a sweet fun
way you know in another shot the fam of
three poses for a selfie Kaylee with her
arm wrapped around her man while he
cradles their little girl but seriously
it's the itty bitty yawn and Tiny pastel
Easter dress for me I think she might be
a little bit of a go-getter definitely
like Tom and I but uh not stop non-stop
moving which is exactly how I am Kaylee
and Tom welcome their daughter to the
World on March 30th sharing these pics
from the hospital calling Matilda the
new light of their their lives they
asked on my what's your plan have you
read books I have no plan and I've read
zero books so that's the type of Mom I
will be after revealing she was pregnant
in October Kaylee talked all things baby
with E.T I trust the process
um Tom has Googled enough for the both
of us and Kaylee's Big Bang Theory
co-star Jim Parsons told E.T she was
ready for the job she was a mother-like
figure to me for many years on Big Bang
even though I'm tremendously older than
her what's wrong is she upsetting you
because I can make her go away
no she's the only reason I've I've
stayed this long
she's a comforting presence and um
no I don't know I don't know it was a
pleasure to work with her day in and day
out she's a very warm person I think
that child's lucky to have her for a
mother
enjoying her new
home she told us she has no plans of
being a stay-at-home Mama she's gonna
come to work with me you know Tom and I
both love what we do and we we've really
made a commitment to each working at
different times and we'll kind of trade
off so that's really that is our goal
and we're hoping I think that's going to
work for us but um who know again who
knows where this was the first for both
of us
foreign